البيت الابيض قال اننا نعتقد ان هذه
الضربات كانت ناجحه لا نعلم عدد المسلحين
الذين قد يكونوا قتلوا او او اصيبوا ولكن
فعليا وبفعل اخلاء هذه المواقع مسبقا بعد
هذه المده من التحذير برايك ما هو التاثير
الفعلي لهذه الضربات حتى الان طبعا لان
البيت الابيض قال انها
مستمره محمد البيت الابيض توعد ونفذ هذا
امر يعتبر بالنسبه له وكانه جزء من عمليه
ترميم الردع اثنين الامكنه التي استهدفت
والاهداف يعني يتم الحديث عن مراكز قياده
وسيطره اماكن بنى تحتيه مهمه وبالتالي حتى
ولو كانت قد اخليت قبل فتره لانه كانت
العمليه تقريبا معروفه مسبقا يبقى اليوم
تدمير البنى التحتيه هذا الامر قد تعيق
عوده هذه القيادات هذه القوى الى هذه
المنطقه يعني اليوم اذا تحدثنا عن
اهداف من دير الزور وحتى البوكمال هي
اهداف كبيره جدا هي اهداف مهمه لانها
تسيطر على خط او محور المقاومه من العراق
البو كمال الى سوريا والى لبنان وبالتالي
هي مهمه
لتواجد فاذا هذه
العمليه تحقق شيء ولكن هي عمليه ترميم
الردع يبقى مده هذه العمليه امر مهم جدا
وهو قال البيت الابيض في بيانه انه لا
يسعى الى الصراع مع ايران في الشرق الاوسط
ولكننا الولايات المتحده لن تتردد في
الدفاع عن قواتنا هل من المحتمل ان تطال
هذه الهجمات مواقع اخرى مجموعات وميليشيات
اخرى انا اعتقد ان هناك شيء قد دبر قبل
فتره
المعادله الاقليميه هناك فيها تقييدات لن
يذهب الى حرب مباشره هي رساله هي تدمير
يعني ذكر اسم فيلق القدس والميليشيات
التابعه لها ان تاتي الطائرات من بعيد
تاتي القاذفات الاستراتيجيه من بعيد
والقادر على حمل رؤوس نبويه هذه امر من
احدى رسائل الردع لترميم هذا الردع الذي
سقط بعد الاعتداءات اكثر من 100 60 اعتداء
على القوات الامريكيه وبالتالي المقتل
في البرج 22 لا اعتقد ان هناك عمليه
مباشره مع ايران بالعام 88 الرئيس بايدن
استهدف البحريه الايرانيه ومن ثم منصات
النفط ولم يضرب الداخل الايراني ولماذا
ستضرب الداخل الايراني وفتح جبهه جديده في
الوقت الذي تسعى فيه الى الاستقرار في
المنطقه ومعالجه موضوع غزه